My eczema has been flaring up so bad lately.
I've not been taking care of myself.
I've been really stressed,
so my palms always tend to look a little bit rough.
I take the C D S. 0 1 daily.
Symbiotic you can take in this little travel container,
which I do. I always do two pills in the mornings,
and it's so good for my gut.
Is a 24 strain probiotic blend.
Helps me with feeling bloated.
And every time that my skin gets bad,
I look at my gut, what I'm eating,
and what I'm putting into my body,
and I see a massive difference when I use seed and when I don't.
So if any of you guys want to try seed and you felt bloated,
or your skin hasn't been great,
or you just feel all around sluggish,
a lot of the times, it's worth it
looking at your gut and looking into taking a good probiotic.